and our feature presenter today is
Professor Bernie Roth
so Bernie is the brodny H Adams
professor of engineering at Stanford
University he earned his PhD in
mechanical engineering from Columbia
University and has honorary PhDs from
the University of Paris and the
University of Cassino he has published
widely in the areas of design creativity
education kinematics and robotics and
has many awards for both his teaching
and research he has served as a director
for several corporations and has held
top leadership positions in several
international professional societies
he has also a co-founder of Stanford's
b-school where he now serves as the
academic director and his latest book
the achievement habit was published in
July 2015 by HarperCollins and now I'd
like to turn the floor over to Bernie
hello everybody thanks for joining in
and I would say good morning or good
afternoon but it depends where he was so
whatever it is good to you I just want
to start off by saying something about
the title and the title has the word
success in it and achieving it and I use
these words in a kind of unusual way in
that most people think success means
becoming Emperor empress of the universe
what I mean by them is that you have a
good life and that you feel good about
yourself and people feel good about you
and basically when you die you friends
who eulogize you don't have to lie and
you can define what all that means for
you personally but the main thing we're
going to talk about is problems and I
think it's important to understand
something about what I mean by problems
and for me problems are a life force
it's actually what makes us tick there's
actually a story I like very much that's
a novel written in the 1860s in Russian
Czarist Russia and the main character's
name is Oblomov and that's the title of
the book and for the first 200 some odd
pages of the book the main character
never leaves his bed and it's because
he's a very wealthy person
everyone takes care of everything for
him and the idea is if you have no
problems you have nothing to do why get
out of bed and of course the book is
just a critical statement about the life
of the aristocracy and in Czarist Russia
but I think it's a really important
point I find that when I have problems
have things I'm concerned about things
that doing I
it's an exciting part of my life it's
it's kind of what makes me tick and I
think we all do it that way we may or
may not think of it that way consciously
but it's important so for me the problem
with the word problems is that it sounds
bad when in fact it's good so I think
that if you understand that the kind of
people around me who are you know being
on entrepreneurship and all that they
say problems are opportunities and was
the bigger the problem the bigger the
opportunity now that may be the extreme
view for you but it is it is actually
true that solving problems is a pleasure
and it's actually necessary to get along
in life now most of us do a good job at
it and occasionally we get stumped and
I'm going to talk to you about what
happens when we get stumped a little
later on but first I want to talk to you
about successful problem solving for
others because it's easy if we look at
how we do it for others to understand
what we don't do right when we do for
ourselves so one of the things we do
when we solve problems for others is we
come up with a problem statement I
prefer using the word point of view
rather than a problem statement because
of it implies that in fact the thing
we're working on is subjective it's not
an objective reality so we say problem
statement implies more something that's
objectively given in fact all the time
there's a subjective view to it and the
way we do it is we get a phrase
describing a specific user which is very
an important point
who was solving the problem for then a
phrase specifying a need and then a
phrase giving an insight specifying what
but not how the solution
needs to accomplish and I'll give you a
specific example that's to make it more
concrete
so in of course I taught the students
came up with the problem statement which
was Maria a poor single mother needs
financial know-how so she can use her
money efficiently now if you look at
that statement
Maria is what it's about there's a need
financial know-how and what it would
accomplish would be to get her money
together to use the money efficiently so
that's kind of the framing of it and
when you see that you could see this an
insight employed in here and that is if
she gots more knowledge she's going to
do better with the money now that's an
assumption and it may not be true she
may be a spendthrift sis she may know
everything there is to know about money
you still not do well about it so you
have this assumption and you have to
test it if you're going to solve the
problem in this case the students worked
with some janitors at Stanford and they
tested their insight and they found that
giving some a small amount of knowledge
change these people's lives that this
woman was able to save $1400 in six
months on a salary of less than $40,000
so she was saving nine percent of her
income on which she had never done
before
but by virtue of them getting giving her
access to banking by virtue of them
giving her some knowledge and things
like that so that was in fact a
life-changing thing both for the people
that the problem was solved for and also
for the people solve the problem because
they went and made a company based on
that insight and the company did very
well it's won all sorts of awards and
basically what the company does is it
ties people to financial institutions
using a cell phone not a smartphone just
an ordinary cell phone and it speaks to
them in their own language and it's been
so successful that the companies call
juntos which means Spanish means
together and there is now there in 12
countries of course four continents
dealing with some of the biggest banks
so this is just an example of how if you
have the right problem sort of magic can
happen if you pursue it and that's kind
of the point of what I'm going to talk
about for you yourself in your own
personal life and sort of question what
we that we're really concerned about
it's not so much what was done in
classes and the more formal methods we
use in what we call design thinking but
problem solving for yourself applying
the same ideas and techniques and so
what do we what are we gonna do how come
you ever think of this
you're in it I know I haven't met you
but I know you're intelligent you're
intelligent enough to sign up for this
webinar so that shows you have a highly
intelligent person and how come people
like you and people that I work with
every day and I myself and people my
family and people and my friends we get
stuck and we lose sleep over simple
problems they're not like rocket science
problems as we say and they're not
generally things like peace in the world
forever and you know the global issues
we generally lose sleep over very small
problems which have to do with our
relationships with our family with our
work with with kind of the small
everyday issues of our lives so how come
you you felt harder problems everyone I
work with has solved our problem
how come you stuck with problems like
that and I've talked to thousands of
people over the years and everyone
really has problems that they don't that
they lose sleep over I only met one
person actually who's claimed he didn't
have any problems of falling asleep he
happens to be the youngest mayor of the
city of Stockton right now I haven't
checked with him recently but I'm sure
he's losing sleep over something so I
think it's universal oh so what can go
wrong well in most cases what goes wrong
is you're using an old answer instead of
a new question you think you're dealing
with the question what you're dealing
with an answer
I'll give you a simple example of that
that happened in my life it's a very
trivial example but it makes the point
very nicely
I had a friend visiting me and I wanted
to take him up to the wine country and I
didn't have a car available so I rented
a car and we went and we were we spent
the nice time and eventually we were
running out of gasoline so we went into
a gas station and at that point the
drama started I went to look for the
button that releases the curve on the
gas tank and I looked everyplace I have
ever had one in any car to have been I
couldn't find it and then I took out the
manual in the glove compartment to see
if I could find it and then suddenly a
miracle happened a car of the similar of
make drove up this cinema make Simla
model so I ran up to the woman I said
this is a stupid question but can you
tell me where the button is to open the
cover on the gas tank and she said there
is none okay so I could have just gone
over and opened the cover and it would
really not been a problem mainly angry
so it's not it's tricky I wasted 10
minutes of my life it's no big deal but
it does show what happened I had the old
answer which is find the button in order
to get to the gas tank the real the new
question was how do I open the cover so
I was really working on the wrong
problem and that's exactly what happens
a lot of times so let's talk a little
bit more about it well if you look at
something like bike riding as an analogy
most people think they know the rules of
bike riding but if you're gonna ride
bikes at a higher level
there are rules which is first seem
counterintuitive for example if you ride
a bike really well you're not using the
handlebars to steer the bike you're
using your bodyweight to steer the bike
you don't sit on the seat if you want to
win the race I got news for you if you
want strace is they're not they're not
sitting on the seat and you're certainly
not pushing on the pedals I'll tell you
that much you know people have clips and
they're pulling and they've been and
it's coming out of the rest of your body
not the part of the foot it's the forces
coming from within you so these are
three rules which in bike ride we seem
after intuitive if you're an amateur
well I want to do the same thing to you
in problem-solving I want to give you a
set of three rules which are really
important rules if you're going to solve
problems in a better level then you've
been doing it up till now and my three
rules are don't use answers as questions
I'll explain these in greater detail
that's what the talk will be about but
don't use answers as questions is the
first rule don't use reasons is the
second rule and don't confuse trying
with doing so those to me are the three
primary rules of trying to solve
problems at a higher level and I will
now explain to you in some detail what I
mean by these if you stuck really if you
literally stuck the chances are very
strong you're treating a wrong answer as
a right question and that's universally
true I found that in my consulting work
I found that in working with PhD
students I find that in my work my
family I find that in my job I find that
everywhere in my life that that's kind
of what happens and so the question is
how do you get unstuck if you start how
do you get yourself it's if you got the
gum on the issue how do you get rid of
it
well as I say the rule is don't use
answers as questions what do I mean by
that well here's here's something that
happened this is a true story I was
working with the group large group of
people and I asked them what is your
what do you lose you sleep over and this
one woman said I really can't find the
spouse I've tried everything I've gone
on the internet and stuff and so the way
so she was stuck she's tried everything
she so the way I would unstuck her is I
would say what would it do for you if
you solved your problem okay so what
would you do so so what we were saying
was this the answer to this is the
answer to some problem what is finding a
spouse the answer to or the way I said
it to her is what would it do for you if
you found the spouse she said I'd have
companionship okay so what happens then
is we've gone to getting companionship
is really the question she wants to work
out so the question is how does she get
companionship once she does that and
forgets about for the moment finding a
spouse the solution space opens up
tremendously because how might I find a
companion has in addition to finding a
spouse meet friends online take classes
get a pair join a club go to jail etc
etc etc so you can get companionship and
lots of lots of ways so what's happened
by reframing the problem is you've
opened up the solution space and that's
one of the magic that's very important
to understand now to do that you have to
be willing to let go of the original
finding a spouse idea
now it's ironic because I've been
married for a very long time and one of
the big issues in my life in my marriage
is companionship because I'm busy
talking to you on the webinar and doing
a lot of other things and I'm not giving
my wife as much companionship as I like
since we've been married for over 60
years I don't think she'll divorce me
but it's an issue okay
so the idea is if if this woman found
the spouse he might not give a
companionship he might be even worse
than me okay so she wouldn't really be
solving a problem so what she's done is
she's taking an old answer which is get
a spouse for a new question which is
really finding companionship and if she
refrains it it opens up and in fact she
might do better finding a spouse if she
wasn't so needy for companionship so
that's the basic idea
I'll give you an amusing version of it
which came up in a workshop I did which
I liked very much this woman had the
problem that her boyfriend was snoring a
lot and she couldn't she just couldn't
handle it she they went to doctors they
had surgery they did all sorts of
medical things and nothing worked
so again I said well what would it do
for you if your boyfriend stopped
snoring
she said I'd be able to get a good
night's sleep okay so now the problem
she should be working on is a good
night's sleep
forget about stop
snoring and if you open it up and say
how do I get a good night's sleep
there's many possibilities right like
including changing the boyfriend
which is a good one was sleeping the
other room or earplugs and so forth and
so on so the poor guy could snore and
you could sleep so it's again it's this
whole idea of trying to solve the wrong
problem and and even if he if he stops
snoring maybe she still wouldn't get a
good night's sleep
maybe bother in other ways I don't know
so the point simply is if you know what
you really want to be after make sure
that's what you're working on now this
thing it's and what happens is I hate to
do this with Stanford freshmen because
they say but but I didn't get a spouse
but I didn't stop snoring they won't let
go of the original problem and they and
it's a coda it's a freshman syndrome
it's okay because once you're graduated
you realize in life it's much better to
disappear problem to solve it if you
disappear your problem it's gone forever
whereas if you solve it to come back and
haunt you so it's really interesting to
it's okay to let go of the original
thing and not just cling to it because
that's what you chose originally okay so
in my case I never found the button to
open a gas tank I never found that
button but I'm sleeping very nicely
because I had a full tank of gas and
went on with my life and that's
analogous to everything you have to be
learning to let go of the wrong thing
which was an answer to the wrong problem
all right now I'll give you some really
powerful examples of this this is a
project that some students that did I
have to do with premature children so
when a baby is born prematurely it must
stay warm or it will die it cannot
manufacture enough heat by itself you
need it do it externally and the way
it's done in most of the world is with
things called incubators we have these
at the Stanford Hospital you have them
almost universally in places where
people have hospitals and what a group
of doctors came to us from Nepal and
they said look we have these incubators
they're donated from they cost $20,000
did--no donated from India but we have
some problems
one problem is they keep breaking and we
can't repair them and the other is that
you need electricity if there's no
electricity there's no warmth and the
baby dies and in a pal the electricity
is intermittent at best so the problem
they gave us well could you keep fixing
incubators and make sure they work so
before the students went in they
probably worked on battery backups to
keep the electricity going and to
redesign it with fewer parts to make it
simpler and then they went to Nepal and
they were horrified because they found
out that the incubators are in the
clinics the clinics are in the villages
in the towns many of the mothers are up
in the hills they can't get there in
time even if these works even if the
incubators were perfect they work the
mothers can't leave their other children
let alone they let the baby die they
they just can't get there in time a lot
of things indicated this was the wrong
thing to be working on okay so they stay
free framed it and they understood they
needed a point of view which took care
of the mother and the child the question
was the mother and the child would use
in the need was to keep the baby alive
and so they invented something that
looks like the well you could just say
the problem here in terms of reframing
it is to make the machine work that's
the wrong problem the idea is to save
the children so if you save the children
you can do other things so they came up
with something which looks like a
sleeping bag and the magic is it has
inside of it a bladder which is made of
a kind of wax like material which when
you heat it it melts and it absorbs a
lot of heat and it takes about five
hours together give them off the heat
and it keeps the baby at the right
temperature and you could melt it with
anything you don't need electricity you
could use electricity but you could boil
water you could use the Sun so you melt
the wax anything you win anyway you had
can and you're not relying on
electricity and it's saved over 300
thousand babies at this point and there
was a nice moment when they were
whydid to the old White House and this
gentleman was nice enough to say nice
things about it so it's an example of
reframing the problem for the right
problem in this case it wasn't fixed the
incubators and was keep the babies alive
and another one which is also a classic
one it has to do with someone a friend
of Alice who works at General Electric
his name is Doug deeds and he designs
MRI machines for children
he designed at one point and what
happened is he designed the machine you
can see there and he went into a clinic
to see how it was going and he was told
that they loved his machine the nurses
love this machine and then he was so
sort of horrified to find out that about
eighty-five percent of the children have
to be sedated before they can go into
the machine is so terror from terrorized
terrified by the machine and he never
saw the machine from the pointing of a
child we sort of asked to crawl into the
mouth of metal monster and he realized
that really he had had talked to some
children so he went around talking to
children that were chronic patients and
all that and when he found out when he
talked to some one child that was a
cancer patient that her life was sort of
devoid of any adventure or any
excitement that her brother had who was
well you know had all these trophies and
she had sort of a very spare life
because of her medical issues and he
figured well what she really needs in
her life is excitement and adventure and
all that so when he did is he repaint he
didn't touch the machines he just
repainted them basically and they made
the machines as part of an adventure
series so the top right one shows a
pirate ship and you have to hold still
so the Pirates don't find you and this
or the other one is underwater and and
what he did is before the children came
they made a comic book showing rays
going through your body where you see
bones and they got knapsacks for the
children so they made it in as
rather than a medical experience and the
sedation rate dropped down from eight
and a half percent to about 1% and
children were heard saying mommy can we
come back tomorrow okay so what happened
is he reframed the problem again from
one of does the machine work you know
which it didn't because his children
well getting sedated all that to one
where not only to save him but to give
them an adventure to give them something
delightful and he found that need by
saying what was he really trying to do
so that's the idea
so that's kind of rule one make sure
you're working on the right problem if
you most of us solve problems all the
time we were always working on the right
problems except when we're not and when
we're not those are the problems we lose
the sleepover and those are the problems
to reframe so if you just you're just
going along your life and you're solving
problems and everything is great don't
worry about it you don't need anything
I've said forget about it
on the other hand if you losing sleep
and things are bad and you don't know
what to do give it a shot
reframe the problem and simply the way
to reframe it is really simple just say
what would it do for me if I solve the
problem that will give you a new problem
work on that new problem forget about
the original one it's magic it really
works very very well
but you have to be big enough not to
hang on to the original problem and you
have to be big enough not to lie to
yourself the problem is most of us lie
to ourselves we have a certain
self-image and we don't tell ourselves
the truth why we want to solve this
problem so you have to be truthful about
what it is you want to get out of the
problem and if you do that then you're
gonna the right thing so if this woman's
just a companionship because she just
made that up and she didn't want to tell
me some other nastier reason she wanted
to get married like she wants a rich guy
to take care of her or whatever it is
she's met it's not going to help but if
you tell yourself the truth then it will
help and you will often the solutions
will be right out there in front of you
and often it almost solves itself so
that's the first one the second world
reasons one they give ask yourself
what's the purpose of reason
in the world why do we have reasons well
I've asked myself that and I thought
about it a lot and I've come up with the
following answer the only use of reasons
is to seem to be reasonable that's the
only use of reasons to seem to be a
reasonable person so for example if I
did something if I went over and I to
some arbitrary person on the street and
I kicked them and they said well why did
you do that I say I don't know I'm not a
reasonable person but if I kick them and
I said you reminded me of that kid in
the fifth grade who used to bully me
then I have a good reason for kicking
him right so I'm a reasonable person
okay so that's absurd but in general
that's that's the level for most reasons
they're really not useful but and who
cares well they can be harmful and
that's the point about that so I'll say
a lot more about that right now the
first thing to understand is there's no
one reason for any human behavior we
have very complicated people and
whenever we do takes into account our
history our connection to other people
our connections to our friends and it's
not just the thing it's health so if
someone asks me Bernie will you do me a
favor and do something I might say yes
and if you say why'd you do that so well
he asked me to do it but the same if a
different person asked me I might say no
with all the same circumstances because
of my history with the person so our
lives are very complicated we go way
back in the past in terms of our DNA and
how we do things that never is one
specific thing so what happens is if
someone asks your reason or you need a
reason for yourself you'll pick the one
reason that makes you look good you'll
pick the one reason that makes you look
okay so for example whenever I give this
talk at this point I noticed my mouth is
dry which it is at this moment okay and
if you say to me why is your mouth dry I
say well I've been talking a lot that
seems reasonable right but I don't tell
you that last night I had a bottle of
wine for dinner
I don't tell you I'm always chronically
dehydrated my wife says I never drink
enough and say I don't tell you all of
those other things in my history which
would lead to me not necessarily having
a dry mouth even if I took the life okay
so what I do is I take the one simple
thing in this very complicated set of
things I don't know the reason my mouth
is joy it's just this joy right okay and
all these things are true that I just
said to you and a few others I don't
want to tell you contribute to it okay
so I picked the language as I'm talking
a lot fine and that's reasonable and who
cares the problem with that is really
awful reasons or an excuse and if you
use them as excuses they don't let you
accomplish what you want to accomplish
and by using the reason you let yourself
off the hook my epiphany on this came
many years ago I was um I was on a board
of directors of a company in Berkeley
and I would periodically go to the board
meeting by driving from Stanford Palo
Alto the freeway to Berkeley and to the
meeting off the Berkeley campus
somewhere and I was always late I was
laid in every meeting and when I came in
I said there was a lot of traffic on the
highway and I came in I said gee I'm
really sorry I'm late it's so much
traffic on those days was highway 17 so
much traffic on highway 17 and they say
that's okay Bernie as long as nothing
happened but then I was it wasn't okay
because these people had lives too and I
was being abusive and I was keeping them
waiting and at one point I realized I
should either get there on time or I
should leave the board and I realized in
a way I would my behavior was insulting
to them because I wasn't giving them a
no valence in my life I wasn't giving
them enough it wasn't important what was
more important was the last few phone
calls I took before I let no cellphones
in those days the last few phone calls I
took my office before I left the
teletype message I had to send out a
conversation I had with a colleague in
the hall and by the time I got to my car
if there was no traffic in Palo Alto no
traffic on the highway
and Berkeley I would have made it but
there was traffic so I didn't make it
and I blamed the traffic but of course
the realization was I was not leaving
early enough I wasn't giving it enough
valence as I say in my life once I had
that I changed my life from becoming the
person who was always late for
everything to the pain the backside that
starts everything on time that's always
on time and is never late and it really
simply it makes my life so much simply
in terms of driving I don't have to do
near-death experience system I'm only
five minutes late and stuff of that
nature and this is simply is that once I
was willing to tell myself the truth and
not say it's the traffic I could handle
it it's simple as that so that's a
really important thing to understand and
reason basically I think that the best
position to have is that reasons are
all reasons are basically
even if you don't intend them
to be that way because you don't know I
mean the people put subjects into MRI
machines and they've had them do take an
action and then give a reason for the
action and it turns out the parts of the
brain that fires first is the one that
does the action the part that comes up
the reason is after so basically you do
what you do and then you make up a
reason for it
most it's on you're an automatic mostly
you don't think about walking you don't
think about breathing you don't think
about talking you just talk it comes out
you know you don't said then you say why
did you say that then I'll think of a
reason why I said I just said it I don't
know why I said it and it's the same
thing you don't know the reasons for
these things and it's supposed to be
reasonable to have a reason for
everything but it doesn't work that way
I don't know if you've had this
experience I've had it many times I make
up my mind to do something and then
something I'm doing something else you
know all the time like they'd have like
people make up not that they're gonna
die even the eating can deal with it do
this they didn't they do wrong so you're
not in control I Got News for you
there's something very complicated
controlling so the reasons is just to
cover for being out of control basically
so basically
if you just keep the idea to reason some
it's really an important thing
so it's better to keep silence than
people then yeah you don't need
the reasons you often do now no one
cares what the reasons are it's a
question of what you did or what you
didn't do not what the reason is the
reason is irrelevant okay so the main
thing is do not try this at home I
I'm just fearful that you're gonna go
home and tell everyone in your life the
reasons of that doesn't work
I've never once told my wife for reasons
of never once told my children
the reasons of I never once
told my biking buddies their reasons are
never once told anyone I work
with your reasons of it's the
best way possible to ruin a relationship
but the person you can tell yourself and
it's really important to tell yourself
that way and to just know that and if
you say something you realize it's
and you're it's okay but just
say to yourself I'm never gonna do that
again and you'll do it again but
eventually you'll stop whereas if you
just keep in doing it and don't notice
that you'll never stop so if you want to
change your behavior if you want to
improve just keep in mind that the
reason you just said it even with the
best of intentions is pure so
don't give reasons unless you have to I
mean don't be a jerk if someone says
what's the reason for this tell them
something okay but if you can't do not
give reasons I get I have this
experience where I get maybe four or
five emails a month from students in
nowadays it's China or Iran or Pakistan
but want to come to Stanford to do a PhD
with me and some of them are really
well-thought-out messages and they've
researched me and all that and I could
ignore them I don't know of them
anything but I felt uncomfortable so
what I used to do is give them some good
reason I can't do it for some excuse so
I'm sorry I don't have any money or I'm
going on sabbatical and whenever I gave
them a reason they push back so if I
don't have any money they say I have a
rich uncle well if I'm going as fast I
can wait a year professor and they would
go on and on until I just trunk
and I have a bad feeling about now that
I have this epiphany about reasons I
don't give them reasons I get the email
I say sorry can't help you good luck and
what happens is about 90 percent the
time gave back an email saying thank you
for answering my email professor it's
the end of the story it's such such an a
good example of they don't need a reason
they just wanna know you're gonna let me
know you're not once they know it's over
the drama is over
don't move on I'll go to somewhere else
and it's really important to keep that
in mind does not use reasons unless you
really have to okay so that that's
that's the second rule okay and it's
really important we have a kind of funny
thing we have a thing people I work with
that we all know this idea so we have if
someone gives you reason like for
example we have some faculty member will
get up in a meeting or say well the
reason I can't do this is the Dean said
blah blah blah
we go that that's a good reason with a
lot of O's in there like five or six
hours meeting it's so the coach
for us is we don't we just say that's a
good reason and you could do that for
yourself really it really helps if you
give yourself a reason for something
your head
just tell you something that's a good
reason and you'll get a lot of insight
because it's okay and finally
come to the third rule which is not to
confuse trying with doing okay and
that's kind of an interesting thing now
if you're a fan of Star Wars you're
quivering at this point because you
don't know that Yoda was wrong I always
prefer at this point I'm afraid I'm
gonna be struck dead but so five gotten
away with it there is a try there is a
truck I know what they're saying in the
movie I have no problem with that but in
real life there is a try and there's
nothing wrong with Troy trying is okay
it's just not doing it's just something
else it's another activity which is good
and there are all sorts of different
activities which are okay one of which
is called doing and it's important not
to confuse all these other things which
look like it with doing let me explain
that to you so that to do you need to
have an intention so first of all what
is your
tension okay if you don't have any
intention it's just a pipe dream
pipe dream refers to people who used to
smoke opium and dense and smoke a pipe
with opium and dreamt about all sorts of
wonderful things so we all have
wonderful dreams we all have pipes
there's nothing wrong with it
hi for you some wonderful if you don't
have to smile have opium it's wonderful
left pipe dreams we have dreams let's
eat whether they are it's great to have
also it's a fan thesis there's nothing
wrong with it but that's not your
intention that's just a dream okay
that's one and if you have something
that you really have an intention to
doing are you willing to give it
attention it's so you need these two
things you need to have intention and
you need to have attention so if you
have an intention to do something it's
not gonna happen unless you give it
attention
it requires there's a word that not many
people know even if you're a native
speaker it's called
Malaya tea and a lot of people
experience the lay of tea now with
loyalty means is the least possible
effort you can possibly put into
something so you have a real good idea
I'm gonna start a business and I'll
think about it for a while and maybe all
I don't know maybe I'll do something
tomorrow
that's fillet of tea the lengthy is just
it's one step beyond the pipe dream
you're sort of gonna implement but it's
a little too much to get out of bed or
too much work
so that's alright so that's not no
attention if you have a lady you don't
have attention so I think you can make a
little chart which I made for you to see
and on one axis longer the vertical axis
I plot intention the horizontal axis I
plot attention and we can talk about
four states of being the lower-left
state is a pipe dream when you have very
little attention and very little
intention so it's something you just
dream about you have no intentional
attention if you go up on the left-hand
side to the top one you have something
where you have an intention but there's
no attention of being given to it
that's the lady the other intention to
do it but you don't give it any
intention you don't you have an
intention to do you don't give it any
attention and then on the right-hand
side on the bottom you have what's
called trying trying is when you have an
intention to do something and you give
it a little attention you give it a
little attention and it might work it
might work it might be simple it might
work and it's fine it'll happen might
happen on the other hand if it requires
a lot more attention or you would
encounter an obstacle or something you
don't do it it doesn't happen and then
finally on the top quadrant on the right
we have doing doing requires both
intention and attention you have to
intend to do you do it and you have to
give it the attention it requires now
all four states as far as I'm concerned
to find there's nothing wrong with pipe
dreams there's nothing wrong for loyalty
there's nothing wrong with trying
there's nothing wrong with doing it
could even be better to try I'll give
you an example that happened in my life
my wife hates when I tell the story but
I think it's perfect she's not listening
so I'll tell you the story we were we
were coming home from San Francisco we
passed the movie theater called The Roxy
which is a kind of funky theater in the
Mission District that shows movies you
don't see anywhere else and I noticed
the line over around the rock she was
bigger than I've ever seen was going
around the block and I noticed on the
marquee it was a movie about a musical
group and the group was there I had
never heard of them but clearly all
these people were there must be great so
I saved your life let's go to her movie
she said no I'm tired let's go home I
said come on let's go to movie she
finally relented she said okay well
let's go I said okay jump out of the car
buy the tickets I'll go find a parking
space ten minutes later I come back and
my wife is not online she's just
standing in front there take a booth I
say well how come you're not online she
said this sold out I said well how come
you're not online
she said didn't you hear me to sold out
I said yeah but you stay here and I went
along the line and I you know got two
tickets somehow
and we went to the show and it was a
great example where my wife was trying
and she got an obstacles they were sold
out so she gave up it's good reason
they're sold out it's good reason not to
go right so I was doing didn't matter
sold out or not I was gonna get those
tickets come hell or high water I was
doing now it turns out in this case it
was terrible trying little bit much
better than doing she never know yeah
sometimes you can get killed though so
I'm not voting
I'm not vote and really in life
sometimes it's really fun to try and it
doesn't happen but it's a difference
between trying and doing you understand
that I had an example where I was
supposed to go to a meeting that I
didn't I didn't want to go to I was sort
of obligated to go to it it was in
Dallas Forth Worth and I came to the San
Francisco Airport and it was a miracle
all the flights to dallas/fort Worth
were cancelled because there was a
snowstorm so I called up the people I
said sorry I can't come as snow he said
we understand thanks all that now the
truth is if I wanted to if my life
depended on getting to Dallas Fort Worth
snowstorm or not it was closed or not I
would have gotten there but I didn't
want to go
I was trying I was 40 I was gone I gave
it a good try it didn't happen it was
great it was the best thing in the world
that I was trying but if I was doing it
wouldn't have stopped me and that
illustrates the whole idea you will end
when you throw doing stuff you'll have
obstacles but the magic comes in walking
around the obstacle and not letting it
deter you and often you get to a much
better solution than you would if you
didn't do that so it's important doesn't
see the difference and again I'm not
voting on all on any of the four I'm
saying just know which state you want to
be in and don't confuse which one you
are and you can you can you can go from
one to the other is no problem if I have
to kill someone in order to do and it's
against my moral principles I'm not
gonna do it I'm gonna change my mind I'm
gonna stop I'm gonna try try one I'm
gonna go have a pipe dream I don't care
what I'm not this you can go from one to
the other just don't know which state
you're in esteem
boy message okay so if you're really
doing an obstacle doesn't stop you and
what is your intention really are you
willing to give the attention turquoise
that's the important thing to understand
and that will get you which quadrant you
really belong in and the other things
that could happen and I'm just gonna
close with this language shapes the way
we think and it's important to worry
about what language are you so for
example instead of using the word but if
you use the word and a lot more you'll
find you'll have a better life instead
of saying you have to do if you say you
want to you have a better life instead
of saying you you will you will instead
of saying you can't you could say you
will not and instead of saying help you
can just use the word assist and so
forth there's a whole bunch of words you
can use that make you like much better
the words change the way you are and if
you use the right words it will make
things go a lot better for you so I've
kind of given you all the ways to might
have at the moment and I want to thank
you for your attention and opening up
now for the second part of this session
we will have questions thank you and I
will head into our Q&A session and we'll
take some questions from our attendees
so burning our first question is how can
you convince your management to rephrase
a problem without giving reasons well
usually it's it's a matter of doing
rather than giving reasons and I had an
experience where three people from a
company organized probably shouldn't
name it came and did one of our
workshops and they went back and they
had an idea and the manager said I'm
sorry we have no room to do it and all
that and he gave them all sorts of
reasons why they couldn't do it and they
they said well they caucused and they
said well let's do it not let's not try
to do it and they they set up a space in
the hallway he wouldn't give him an
office they set up a space in the
hallway and they eventually did it
they went on so it's just a matter of
not it's a good reason that the manager
doesn't want you to do it really if you
look in your heart there are lots of
stories around
I think Emerson's got the cellphones
because the which was a big hit for them
years ago because it's one guy his boss
said he couldn't do it so he went home
in the garage and he made the first cell
phone cameras so it really gets to that
it's really it's a good reason the boss
and the Dean and all that and if you
want to do it you are smart enough to
find the way okay
it's kind of like the old saying where
there's a will there's a way right yeah
um so for our next question with regard
to the lack of gender diversity and
private equity and hedge funds and
unconscious gender biases
how would you refrain the problem that
problem is Pacific okay well the
question is what's the prize it's a
probably you're just telling me a social
situation which you don't like so is it
how do I get more women in Tucson yeah
yeah I'm really stayed you're prone to
stay there big issue so first of all the
best thing would be to just take one
person like yourself or quit but if you
want and just like I did with the woman
with the money thing and just
specifically say who it is what the
issue is and what would happen if you
could find a solution without worrying
about the solution okay and then that
would that would give you a way to work
on it we don't we don't have a problem
yet it's a reframe so but if you gave me
a specific problem let's say what's made
went up how do I get a higher salary so
I would say what would it do for you she
got a higher salary that might be would
give me more respect in the organization
so the question is how do I get more
respect in the organization rather than
the whole if it's not working
I have nothing against you going for a
higher salary hopefully you get it but
that's what I'm saying if you take a
specific question not a general world
issue like peace forever and stuff like
that if you take a specific problem and
say that and you actually have attempted
to solve it you give it an intention and
it's not solving then it's time to
reframe it and you reframe it by saying
what with the specific so what was the
solution to that do for me and so on the
topic of problem solving it requires a
great attitude and perspective how how
do we practice it every day where are
some tips for practicing yesterday
well you practicing it every day like it
or not you're always doing a good job at
it or a bad job at it so the I would say
the word mindfulness which is a little
overused is the answer it's a matter of
not being oblivious but looking at what
you do and maybe going in I don't know
if you keep a diary or something like
that but a good thing might be to go
when you go home at night or in the
morning if you work in the night
write down what happened during the day
in terms of incidents and problems and
what whatever analyze them and say what
you will never do again and what you did
wrong and so be aware of your behavior
and see how it goes and use that as a
way to learn that you know we say
failure is a great way to learn so if
you really do something bad you've
learned make an underline it in red and
don't do it again you'll do it again but
eventually you'll stop if you if you
keep taking notice of it so I'd say
awareness or mindfulness is the key and
don't go unconscious about what's going
to happening every day okay and so sit
down to the next question are there any
ways to help yourself move from the
trying to doing stage any ideas to find
the motivation to keep working even even
though there are many obstacles in the
way yeah well it if you don't if you
don't motivated why bother I mean I many
years ago I was in Bulgaria and I heard
this wonderful saying the guys the
Bulgaria saying is there's no need to do
anything and why is that well if it's
really important someone else will do it
if it's not important why bother so so
there's a lot of wisdom in that you know
if it's not worth doing it's not worth
doing well at all so it's certainly so
just this whole idea you have
do you have to do it you don't have to
do you have a great time just trying it
I'm not voting but if you are motivated
you know if you really want to do
something then you can't let the
obstacles block you there's my favorite
stories my friend Paul he was a swimmer
and he had an axe into the shower and
they had a back surgery in the surgeon
said you can never swim competitively
again and but there was an Olympics
coming up and he wanted to go and he
talked to some guy who was sort of a
guru type and guru said well who can
stop you if you want to do it do it who
guess what the doctor said so he trained
he trained fiercely it was not much time
trained fiercely in a local reservoir
here called Lexington reservoir and he
just qualified he was like the last
person to get onto the team was between
him and so he just got on and he went to
the Olympics and he won a gold medal and
he set a world record he came back he
put the doctors deaths and that was the
point he had a good reason not to go he
said the doctor said it all that but he
was so motivated and he's been a serial
entrepreneur he tells me every time he
does something there's always a blockage
is it was like the accident and getting
around in his way to magic is but he has
the motivation if you don't have the
motivation forget about it do something
you feel motivated about yeah so last
question here this is a question but
what is the approach or the right
problem of solve if you're just liking
your current job and wanting a new job
opportunity you know how can you
rephrase that that problem I don't
understand I mean it seems like you have
this problem it's all solved I don't
know if there's anything to be afraid
you don't like your job and you want to
get a new job opportunity I'd say that
the question is how do I get a new job
opportunity and if you're having
problems doing that say what would it do
for me and if it's well I have a happier
life or a happy thing maybe you could
stay where you are and reframe what
you're doing to make it happier and so
you may have certain constraints that
aren't really there and you know some
people are chronically and I have a
friend who's chronically unhappy and
every job he goes to he has problems
with that so it doesn't matter if he
changes this job or not he has to change
his being so there's that whole aspect
to it but if you're really in a job
that's bad there's no hope and all that
and clearly the answers changed your job
and you'll find lots of reasons why you
can't but they're all just good reasons
so moral of the story there are a lot of
good reasons right thank you very much
Bernie for this awesome talk so we're at
the top of the hour now and it's time to
wrap up if you have any additional
questions about Stanford's professional
programs on design thinking and
innovation please don't hesitate
hesitate to reach out to us directly and
make sure to check your inbox for the
webinar recording within the next week
thank you again for joining us today and
hopefully we can see many of you with us
here on campus in September